I think I'm going to get a two pound box
like 10 bucks a pound pound of that's
gonna be berries and a pound of that's
gonna be turkey a pound of pure protein
in there which is like 400 calories and
probably about 100 grams of protein
here's the life hack with the berries a
pound of berries it's like 150 calories
so you put those together you got like a
550 600 calorie dinner with 100 grams of
protein and 200 grams of carbs and get a
little bit of fiber there too we'll see
how it shakes out all right let's see
what we got oh they only have diced
chicken they usually have turkey I'm
gonna deal with it so we're gonna go
chicken here like I was saying earlier
big strawberry guy big fan FYI actually
I'm gonna eat this for dinner so this is
the chicken I was going for a pound oh
one two six this guy 1.2 so there's 30
bucks you're like man that's a lot of
money yeah Whole Foods ain't no joke but
there we are